this is for all the people that didn't
believe in
me what's happened here and your left
finger well you should have seen the
other
person Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can Salam Alum guys I'm here in
Bosnia and the gun range inah I do look
like I'm the general but I'm not it's
just a hat and my glasses that makes me
look cool but the real General is here
zakum how you
do so obious he doesn't speak that much
English he went through the safety
features of when we're doing going to
the gun rage alhamdulillah you know when
it comes to you know not pointing the
gun at anything or human beings accept
your target zishan we're going to give
you a banana inah you'll be using that
for
now anything how do you no no no the the
the target you're shooting uh and so
don't point out the Target no no you're
going to be in front of me you're my
main target but yeah we're going to for
some safety features I can see behind me
brother and sisters are this full
automatic or semi-automatic
semi-automatic it semi automatic and
these are the pistols yes this is
Semitic good inshallah and we've also
signed the waivers here as you can see
which shows that everything is
alhamdulillah legal it's one of my first
times ever shooting an actual gun I've
tried BB and pellets but I'm sure they
are not the same and that's what it is
in it's just a experience to have alhamd
I call everybody in the UK London around
the world to come and visit the brothers
inshallah and it's it's I mean as Muslim
men as well you know we suffer with a
bit imasc being emasculated in is isan
thank you for that uh in we're going to
go to the gun rage and inallah learn how
to shoot some targets can I put apple on
my friend no please okay all right as
you can see maybe this is the most
dangerous you have seen
me I'm so he said with the left finger
take
out that's how it goes back in got two
magazines here and in obviously we can
hi
it anybody
with you you send me the location who
said what to you bro who is it you don't
need to send no location okay you are
the location I am the
location want some if anybody wants some
we'll give it to you come on but we're
talking about da okay that's that's
that's the biggest weapon that is the
big we're going to put this away then
this is this is this is light work put
this away the magazines we don't need
them at the moment we got the Quran in
our heart yes and we utter it on our
Tong and that is what's one of the
heaviest things on sister that's what we
live and die by take a natural
so don't act a weird way just stand
naturally the most naturally you
know okay now we're talking about the
support
hand let's record as you can see guys
brothers and sisters isan has got
humiliated we don't know where he is
he's I think gone to where is he that's
it the loser usually picks up the things
isan you're doing very good carry on so
when you lose the year they give you a
job you do dishes you make salad for the
team uh so I'm pretty sure you lost you
got disqualified by shooting the wrong
target Smo uh jealousy is not nice it's
one of the disease I'm joking I'm joking
yeah ni he not jealous I had I had I I
hit the big be jealous you you know he
won so he cannot be jealous yeah exactly
I have to be jealous of him but yeah I
had the big one first which means I'm
automatically disqualified but I didn't
know
that
oh you see I'm I'm about to take a step
in up up a notch we start with the
pistols now we're going to go
semi-automatic inshah as you can see the
targets there that's what we're going to
try to get is there any reminders on the
spot I know put on the spot by any
reminders today inah you know Eddie
invited us to come to BOS for the invite
for everything this a lot of fun it's
brilliant aldah and thank you for
joining us Bless but it's very important
you know what the Brotherhood because
when you guys watch our videos it's we
like an in object we're just these
people you just watch but behind the
scenes there's like you know there
Brotherhood meeting sharing reminding
and this what it is you know Allah says
in the Quran be soft towards the
Believers you know and harsh towards the
enemies not your general disbelievers
but Subhan Allah this is something that
we've lost in the YouTube scene you
always see people bickering fighting
each other Etc and one thing I love
about him is this the unity and for
Eddie to even show that about inviting
us to Bosnia taking us out looking after
us feeding alhamdulillah he's someone
that if I'm not mistaken before I came
to Islam I saw a couple of videos before
I came to Islam yours ahed Zaki n so Al
it's very important for us to as
brothers off camera that's a good point
about Islamic brotherhood because I see
people online are spending like tens of
thousands of dollars to go and pay for
Brotherhood that I mean this is gwa if
you want that Brotherhood become a
Muslim and you can get that worldwide
we're in Bosnia this guy is from
Kurdistan we got pakistanis here bosan
from Chicago people from all over the
world I'm a Chinese guy in here speaking
basian with a bunch of Arabs if you want
that Brotherhood become a Muslim Arabs
say don't pay $10,000 to join a network
of high value guys when you could just
become a Muslim and do the same things
we're shooting guns we're traveling the
world we're having fun we're getting to
climb rocks and ride horses and do what
men are supposed to do aldah yeah yeah
and that's what it is and that's how the
companion were and they are Role Models
Brother s to be Islam Brotherhood
cost this is for all the people that
they didn't believe in me
[Applause]
so he's got an AR-15 as you can see and
this is some dangerous bullet so you're
going to say say hello to my little
friend so you're going to see now and
when you're next to it you feel the
shock anytime you shoot like Bumpus you
can feel like an absolute shock Subhan
Allah it's very very interesting
all right guys as you can see I fell off
a horse alhamdulillah my knee uh
yesterday little Graz as you can see
alhamdulillah and the just going up here
and I just realized what's happened here
and your left finger well you should
have seen the other person if there was
one he would be no more however this is
a Ricochet a bullet Ricochet I would to
say Ricochet cuz Ricochet is the actual
bullet I think it's a fragment that when
the bullet exp they said it was a
Ricochet really yeah isn't a ricochet
the bullet brother Ricochet or fragman
Ricochet but anyway the import is
he do brothers and sisters is so
important because me falling off the
horse could have been far worse the
doing your eat in the morning and
evening is so so important guys Subhan
Allah yeah I'm going to put an app there
subh it could things could look me
falling off the horse my ears are
ringing yeah same same so the thing is
brother sisters do your your Salah
protects you it's not my day today
staying away from sins as well and also
when you do your in the morning and
evening because these things could have
been far worse your protects you from
evil eye um Envy jealousy and things
that could harm you physically unless
what Allah subhana will so Ali is about
to fire some things these are the big
things let's go Zan they should have put
you your picture up there come on
noing back to the other side yeah yeah
just okay guys so this is apparently
made in Turkey it's called ATA uh
they've only let me use it cuz I'm the
big boy I'm joking okay ready watch out
focus
focus look are you ready guys go
ahead can has a
number that's the one you missed me
watch did I miss it
yes much talking about the other
one the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tal tells us that our books will be
given and every little atom weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a Masid oh
Allah you helped you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of as if you
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]